final preparations are underway at
Piazza cuatro November in Perugia this
region was once a communist hot spot but
on this evening the spotlight will be on
Georgia Meloni she's a top candidate of
the populist right-wing party Brothers
of Italy and her fans are going wild
we're excited and look forward to her
arriving here
Georgia is more of a friend than a
leader to us
Georgia Maloney is taking the stage the
45 year old is considered charismatic
smart and dangerous
and she knows just what her base wants
to hear
she immediately goes on the offensive
she accuses the left of being aggressive
and calls the EU incapable of tackling
the energy crisis and she claims Italy's
last Administration abandoned the people
but that she'll always put Italians
first
let me explain our stance on migration
they've told you lots of nonsense about
it wait for them with a shotgun no wait
I don't agree with that
[Music]
strives to appear moderate but she
quickly makes clear what she wants she'd
like to see a more heavy-handed approach
to immigrants from the global South
they cause security issues but you can't
get the lefties to wrap their heads
around that they show solidarity with
women who've been attacked as long as
they aren't attacked by illegal
immigrants because then suddenly the
illegal immigrant is more important than
the rape victim
many of her fans can't get enough of her
straight talk it doesn't seem to bother
anyone here that many people in
Maloney's party are supporters of former
dictator Benito Mussolini or that the
flame on his tomb is her Party symbol
s
Italy we should be
so passionate so clear and
comprehensible even when she talks about
complicated issues
however Maloney's critics warned the
right-wing populist is impacting Italy
and its values Antonio piccini is in the
anti-fascist organization anpi which has
a long history
and he doesn't buy Maloney's new
moderate image
flash is never
has gone away still here with us it's
just changing a little bit the face and
new makeup but it's still with us
this is calieri in Sardinia the next day
and Maloney is planning a rally here too
cosimolado won't be there but he says
he'll keep up to speed with how it goes
the Sardinian entrepreneur runs a cafe
and four little hotels on the island but
he's very worried first came covet and
now exploding Energy prices and he's
disappointed by politicians
every Administration lets us
entrepreneurs down both left and right
we need a long-term plan not just
year-long campaigns yes
Maloney's agenda is relatively vague
overall and her party has refused to
play a part in any Administration so far
but that might prove to be an asset
because many Italians want to see new
faces in the cabinet
like Mercedes usai she complains it's
getting harder and harder to make an
honest living in Italy
[Music]
private cleaning company in the kyleri
courthouse but I'm also a substitute
teacher at an elementary school
[Music]
so you need two jobs to make ends meet
[Music]
five to survive
it remains a mystery what exactly
Georgia Maloney has in mind does she
really intend to renounce her party's
post-fascist Heritage we try to ask her
[Music]
[Music]
the candidate isn't interested in
answering questions this evening but
once she's on stage a demonstrator
confronts her despite all the security
precautions
[Applause]
I want the right to marry and adopt
children
okay you want a lot of things everyone
wants something
it's hard to say whether the incident is
real or staged but lgbtq activists
definitely fear the far-right
Nationalist our fear here is that we
would go back in time and instead of
going forward in terms of Rights in
terms of other type of progressive kind
of mindsets uh we would go back to an
Era that we we fear we dread the most
young demonstrators protest again and
again this evening while Maloney
finishes her rally under police
protection
but that certainly hasn't put a damper
on Mercedes usai Spirits does it bother
her how protesters are calling Maloney a
fascist if they call us fascists then
just like Georgia Maloney I don't care
if a lot of Italians feel the same way
the